this is what happened would look like to
me
ok this is hanging out with my old man
my pops how you doing to us and let
visiting the family here in Texas and he
makes this dish which seriously its
heavenly if you haven't had it can you
guess what this is called can you guess
what that is called on my gosh if you
haven't had that yet it's called or miss
a busy my Persian people know what it is
nearly here silver daddy let's talk to
let's talk about teaming together is
that ok let's do it said are you okay to
you want to join us to come on really
getting it is well let's do the three of
us
ok then say hello shake hello shay hello
my little more hug you go really say
hello to everybody
ok feeling can you tell them what our
focus is ready Billy I dylan james david
will one day be a great leader daddy do
we bully people well do people bully us
nope because we're what we lead we love
we respect we improve right you know
today when I'm sitting next to these
kids
my oldest is over there hanging out with
his mommy and
what you want to say you want to say
something to we're gonna take over the
world or what
who are you dealing who's gonna be one
day when you grow up a superhero
wahoo tell us what you gonna be flash
what the whose daddy I don't know who
are you gonna be spider-man who I'm
gonna be spidey man and who's daddy
a credible hulk, not incredible
credible hulk
who's te gusta como some his Superman or
what and what are we gonna do together
we're gonna take over the what
well we can take over the world together
will join you on that journey pop okay
okay
set ascending gonna go with us as well
then go to what now you're gonna be
having out there like this because i
don't know if that's gonna work pop with
with this underwear you got on that we
gotta we gotta do something about that
ok you gonna you gonna need to go get
your superhero outfit you know it's
amazing i'm talking to these guys to do
go get a good word with mommy and
bring back go-go-go show me show me your
muscles
I'm talking to these guys sitting we're
just hanging out and one of the things
that came to my mind is that sometimes
as we age we lose one thing let me tell
what that one thing is we lose that
level of innocence innocence leaves us
we no longer are innocent like a child
were no longer innocent like a kid who
thinks we can take over the world were
no longer thinking like someone who is
thinking anything and everything is
capable of we can pull off anything we
can pull off a miracle right daddy be
careful daddy sent a small papa
here sit next to Daddy say hello to
everybody here sit and say hello to
everybody
what's your name full name magic game
three baby okay what are the full four
things we follow that what are the four
things back and then you and left to
bully do we get bullied
that's right so he comes up to me today
daddy I'm uh your captain america right
and then he says Dylan is who dylan is a
spider-man and daddy is incredible hulk
and we're gonna go take over the world
together right now that thinking as
adults is so we say things like oh
that's so cute you know it's so amazing
well I'm not think like that as adults
anymore why do we look at those are all
innocent but we use that level of
thinking anything is possible
why did we lose that level of childlike
thinking that you know you you're you're
thinking emotionally and validating
logically instead of everything having
to be largely making sure i know you're
gonna be spider-man daddy
wow you mean amazing spider-man wine and
you can be a clean Bowl hope I am I
gonna be good incredible home
yeah okay that's good guess what what
we're gonna be teens we're gonna be good
to me I we have the same team don't know
yeah what do you take opened award
yeah I'm your best friend haha was your
best friend really tickles your best
friend Gary Wells Tico who loves you to
go and make sure you teacher loved you
once love to but I think this more loves
you too
someone let me
that's awesome pictures love me
people who believe in you and me and
everyone that's so amazing isn't it he
says me and everybody always said I know
Joe I have Jojo woh jo j-o Joe yeah John
hi John how do you think what you want
to say hi to your friends want to see
how to Sean and Gracie
hey Amy let's see how shiny Gracie no
Sean and Gracie
ok let's finish this video part so we
can get back to what we're doing so the
point is this hanging out with these
kids ignites ignites the level of
innocence that we have to believe that
anything is possible
so instead of being so logical and
having everything needing to make sense
to illogically use a little bit of your
innocence emotional excitement
enthusiasm to believe that everything is
gonna work out and if you keep that
think and eventually things will work
out your way
I know it's childlike I know it's not
adult like I know it's not
logically educated proper type of
thinking but I had to save anyone that
ever does anything big have a certain
level of childlike innocence in them
that the rest do not have anyways I
gotta let you go because these guys wanna wrestle  and they wanna go take over the world
together in which one pop you want the
star war i don't see star war up there but
what star wars you talking about up
there
okay I gotta go take everybody tonight